here is Tucker Carlson and Tim Scott
going at it over Russia and Mexico
here's I'm just interested because all
measures are relative so Russia's bad
Russia's a threat Putin's evil got it
but the total body count from Russia in
the United States is right around zero
like I don't know anyone who's been
killed by Russia I know people
personally who've been killed by Mexico
the government of Mexico allows fentanyl
to be made in its country and to come
over our border yes remittance is from
Mexico are a huge part of their economy
The Mexican government is party to the
murder of hundreds of thousands of
Americans so why is Mexico less of a
threat than Russia well two things I
think we can walk Andrew gum at the same
time okay but yep frankly here's no
Americans killed by Russia hundreds of
thousands killed by Mexico but Mexico is
our Ally and Russia is our enemy how
does that work well I'm not going to
pretend like I the legislation I have
sponsored and I would sign as president
United States freezes the assets of the
Mexican cartels targets of Mexican
cartels and hopefully eliminates the
flow of fentanyls I do agree with you
that 70 000 Americans losing their lives
on an annual basis is an existential
threat to America that we can solve we
don't have to choose the good news would
you be willing to say to the Mexican
Government your economy runs on
factories right over the Border car
plants for example but many other
manufacturing plants
and we're just going to stop tariffs on
that and tank your economy like tomorrow
unless you stop allowing poison to come
into our country like why not do that
okay so what's interesting here is Tim
Scott didn't totally flub this thing uh
what Tucker was trying to do was make
the clear distinction that what's
happening in Mexico right now the amount
of people that are coming over we've
covered that a gazillion times you get
it the amount of drugs they are bringing
here the crime all of the stuff what is
happening in the Border towns of all of
those Texas cities that nobody seems to
care about until they somehow make their
way up to Martha's Vineyard that as
Americans we should care far more about
that but you guys are always talking
about Ukraine right you guys are always
giving money to Ukraine when we should
either be building a wall we should be
dealing with the 12 million people that
are here all of this stuff basically
what I think you got out of Tim Scott
there was just more of the kind of
nothingness well we can do both at the
same time it wasn't horrible but it
wasn't great so I'm trying to give you a
little bit of a temperature on each of
the candidates
[Music]